so we were just talking about Australia
yeah my friend and I lived there for a
second we're
we're in Sydney and we are planning on
staying there for like a year so we
signed a lease for this apartment and it
was like a college like it was sort of
near a college it was in Newtown Sydney
so it's like an indie sort of like
grungy neighborhood um
back then I don't know what it's like
now but like Indie sort of like uh it
was like what's a good equivalent
Sydney's very commercial though right
like isn't I've heard that I'm playing
with this earpiece I've heard that um
like Melbourne is the really artsy one
right yeah and then Sydney's sort of
like Glam like la la yeah but then you
were living in The Artsy part of it was
like Brooklyn sort of okay okay or
Silver Lake yeah it was like okay that's
sort of like a lot of music venues a lot
of like craft breweries and it was a lot
of like young people living there
because it was cheaper and so we signed
this lease for this just horrendous
[__] apartment like horrendous it was
like 500 bucks oh it's so cheap yeah
yeah it was like
did I say something wrong no no no that
should have been like I love this this
is going great but what was that
this horrible apartment and it's like
it was like shared I didn't even know
what it was technically it was like a
town like little townhouses that were
all shared by different like college
students or whatever and uh then
everything's upside down because it's
Australia and the beds were yeah on the
road right yeah yeah which was super
disconcerting yeah and all the writing
is backwards yeah exactly and it is
crazy how the weather the year is the
opposite though that that was so crazy
to me like it's when like it's summer
Christmas yeah yeah summer Christmas
yeah yeah and right now it would be
going into fall it would be fall I can't
even I can't even do the math I can't
put it together you got to carry the one
I think and then it's tough the math is
tough yeah so we
we're living in this horrible apartment
and and uh just you know like binge
drinking and
drinking uh goon it's called oh my God
that's a drink down there yeah do they
have that here no wow goon bagged wine
wow yeah scoring wow Goring yeah yeah
and uh we're just going most people yeah
please read this yeah yeah but back that
up well that looks like a pillow please
read that most people in Australia know
know about it and many Backpackers drink
it almost daily basically goon is a
general name for Cask wine or boved wine
they're a mixed box boxed Oh I thought
that was a v there are mixed opinions
about Goon on the one hand it's a cheap
drink that tastes good good good ice
cold or mixed yeah that was good the
Australians in the comments are gonna
grade me on that and if you're just
listening we actually have an Australian
man in the studio for this yeah for this
segment yeah yeah yeah how do you you've
never been there I've never and how can
you do that I I dated an Australian for
a little while and I think I don't give
that enough credit but really you know
what it was I watched a bunch of seasons
of
Australia's Next Top Model
which is all these teenage girls just
being like Oh my God we've got a gift
it's a big they gave one time they gave
him like um a puppet or like a stuffed
animal and this girl I was like because
I use this as a
staple of the accent she's like we got
this gift it's a Big Brown Beaver
wait what it was a Big Brown Beaver
I I understood what you said what is
that yeah like a statue I don't know it
must be something that they do on
Australia's next summer no no no it's a
stuffed animal a Big Brown Beaver
and there's somebody named Jody on it
that was like the there it was their
Tyra and her name was Jody so they call
her Georgie yeah Jordy yeah there's that
R sound that gets added
and I wonder if I I haven't asked enough
Australians like do you are you hearing
the r sound that we're hearing because I
feel like they would be like no there's
no R we're not adding an R sound but
we're hearing like a jar it's like d
after every oh there's an R it's a
silent R right and it has really gone
mainstream with how everybody writes
Gnar now yeah yeah yeah you know I'm
glad I'm glad it went big I'm trying to
think of the equivalent
like that they would make fun of us for
just like being losers and not having
Health Care
yeah having
um no you know what's something I've
noticed about British there's a British
thing where they'll say okay so like my
friend's name is Teresa
and her mom would do something which she
would add an R
that isn't there at the end of her name
if it was before a vowel in the next
word so if she's saying Teresa and
Andrea her sister shout out to Teresa
she would say
Teresa and Andrea Teresa and Andrea but
in a British accent Teresa and Andrea
yeah yeah okay and it's a little it's
actually too boring to explain I'll try
to make it really fast but it's because
in Britain they drop the r sound so much
that then they have to like pick it up
again so then they're adding one where
there isn't one because they're assuming
there is one there even though there
isn't basically because it's like they
don't say the r on Ka
you know
um that's far away yeah far but they
added if it if it attaches to another
word to far away right
what is this where words like saw an
idea come before a vowel if there's this
in a British accent there's an
increasing tendency among speakers of
British in British English to insert an
R sound so that Law and Order become Law
and Order Law and Order
and China animals becomes China animals
linguists call this intrusive R because
the r was never historically part of the
world wait what a weird example of China
animals I'm glad somebody's finally
talking about China
Google is like you're gonna read about
the China animals today whether is that
even a real phrase would it be Chinese
animals China animals What are China
animals this is what they're talking
about in England this is what's
happening on the bees yeah yeah they're
like another day and the China animals
are still in the news yeah it feels
feels a little racist I know it's like
maybe they're not it's what they call um
one of those giant pandas they're like
they don't know what to call it yeah
yeah the giant China I'm not exactly
sure what it is but but it's looking
like a China animal it looks like a
raccoon yeah
yeah
so anyways we're living in this
apartment great and uh we're there for
about a month maybe a month and a half
two months maybe and it's like horrible
it's the worst place I've ever lived in
my entire life and but you're having fun
in Sydney we're having fun in Sydney it
was a good time but we were just like
drunk all the time how many are you how
many how many was me and two friends
okay great all Americans oh no one of
them was British okay one was British
yeah Canadian I'm Canadian third yeah so
it was a Melting Pot oh my God beautiful
yeah yeah so we one day were sitting
there drinking and my friends like this
this is a horrible shitty old couch that
we [__] hate it in there and it was
there when we got there and one of my
friends like lifts the cushion and he's
like what the [__] is this and we pull
up all three cushions and the couch is
filled with asbestos wait how do you see
a spec what does asbestos look like
would you guys know what this looks like
yeah you don't know what it look here
pull it up it looks like drywall wow
kind of like fiber glass oh it's that
spray is it that that's something go
back
maybe maybe I'm just maybe it was just
literally drywall
but also why is there drywall on the
couch is the bigger question yeah I know
right yeah don't sketchy sketchy they're
like put a bunch of sheetrock under the
cushions
yeah you know what now that I'm looking
at this I doubt it was actually asbestos
I feel like we're looking at pictures of
like beautiful rocks and gems like
molecules yeah no this looks like Zuma
took a microscope on a China China
animal
yeah I don't really there doesn't seem
to be a uniform uh there doesn't seem to
be any agreement in the photos of
asbestos maybe it was drywall on the
couch
that was the last [__] straw but did
you and you told the landlord yeah we
told the landlord and you were like
we're getting well actually we because
we like facetimed like some you know
like 22 years old like stupid as [__]
didn't know anything yeah yeah and so we
like called my friend's parents or
something like they were like yeah that
definitely does not look good and I
don't know why that would be
in the couch so we ended up leaving
anyways wow and you went back and that
took you back to America no yeah we were
like you know what [__] this stupid
upside down country drywall on the couch
there's [__] couch cushions in the
wall
the landlord is like these [__] kids
think they can do whatever they want
just because they found drywall under
the [__] cushions and they're blowing
up online and they think they can get
out of this [__] ways [__] these kids
man
that's how we do it here oh I lost it
damn no no it was good it was no no no
not good
wow so you go to a better apartment they
maybe cost more money we after that we
were like after that we actually were
like okay you know what's maybe Sydney
like maybe we're done with Sydney and we
traveled up to the Gold Coast and we
actually went to Melbourne as well so
I'm kind of happy that happened because
then we it like forced us to travel
around and yeah yeah see more of the
country which is nice so it took you up
to Melbourne and now I'm going back
you're going back right for the
triathlon yeah yeah Gold Coast is a
coast but it's also a city right yes
there's a city called Google yes right
um my friend shot um some of young Rock
there which I don't think I think it's
not I think it's set in Miami I don't
know where it's at but
it's not set in it's called young rock
yeah it's a show on TV oh okay right now
it was no I think it's done yeah it's
about literally The Rock when I was
young oh really yeah I know it sounds
like rock music yeah yeah School of Rock
not to be confused with young Rock